hello and welcome to this video do I
have the number right no I don't let's
go before fix the number yeah 500 ok I'm
playing limb and hyperaccelerated dragon
yeah I'm I'm always amazed that people
go for this line with taken t5 it's just
bad looks extremely unattractive I don't
know why people opt for it
and I came to Poland c6 square on c5
this looks awful
okay young probably probably be three
and push up a three
Bishop III is interesting it's not the
only myth though the ship III comes into
consideration as well as does taking and
we should be three okay I'm going to do
this and play Bishop III
okay I would absolutely like to prevent
him from castling and I don't know if
I'm possible if I'm able to do it maybe
let's see if I just play as aggressively
as possible like if he takes it would be
one would be seven mm good hindsight I'm
not even sure that b3 was best but
anyway let's see what happens he he more
or less has to take don't know if he
really wants to allow Bishop c5 so this
and look on the seventh so no Castle for
you and here I have a temple move like
Queen to c2 things like that I just
wonder what the best temple move is
Quincy one
[Music]
Bishop c5 is also a possibility after
the Queen move
okay Quincy German whoopsy 894 maybe I'm
94
they're tough business certainly could
have made life easier for me some Howard
Queen a six maybe I was thinking might
be five he just castles after that shoot
hmm you won
you still castles
Knight takes c6 is a move I have no time
to figure it out which 20 seconds Queen
takes Knight g7 is I mean I don't know
what it is but it's interesting enough
that same and part a group g7 should be
fine
unless I'm overlooking something really
drastic which is possible
that looks very dangerous to put it
mildly hmm okay I was a sudden end not
really extremely deserving I think yeah
here I should improve probably here
already I don't think you should get
that far that I have to sacrifice a pawn
I mean really don't don't think this is
any good okay I'm happy up to here but
not sure okay I have a simple move like
Bishop III maybe this is actually
stronger yeah with hindsight's that is
probably better here that Bishop makes
it very difficult for him to castle okay
this is what the engine wants to do
okay what's your type of night age -
okay yeah it's an entirely different
game so I took here you should be three
queen at five and now before I don't
know what that is really good that was
my idea 96 94 I'm actually following the
engine it's the only line that somehow
makes sense it seems even though I
didn't see it you know I saw that I'm
okay
why I thought I would be fine because I
didn't see a really great move than a
spotted queen eight-six my original
intention was this but then he castles
and it is just not working at all yeah
there should be five is an additional
thing but yeah and this this this idea I
saw it of course he doesn't have to take
who came at it doesn't really matter
this is possible
and now best seems to be Bishop takes e5
that's really bonkers and then I have
this one I mean I saw that 95 is an idea
no engine gives 98 my god
no clue engine says equal but hey okay
it took on b7 I took him give age Bishop
age six
yeah and now I was expecting King g8 of
course I mean I'm already winning
they're the tips that I wasn't really
seeing that I thought it should be very
dangerous of course but I didn't see it
as a win
here I was thinking night age five and
it does work yeah I saw this idea that
would have been funnier
so the f5 given by the engine and then
you have to be cool enough to see in six
very nice yeah it's nice this is nice
you had a combination of Bishop and pawn
queen that you cannot stop it yeah made
made made cannot come everything yanqing
e7 ran into made in five I didn't see
that it was made in five funny how is it
made in five actually so check you know
yeah yeah I check on g5 first you what
this first add this first yeah and now
here yeah I know can only donate some
things but it's made at the end funny
major somehow yeah I also entertaining
game hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching